this soccer player's contract is almost
the same amount of money as the NFL has
in team salary cap these contracts are
out of control former Real Madrid star
Kareem Benzema just signed a three-year
wait
643 million dollar contract with Saudi
club al Etihad let's just break that
down real quick in one year he's making
215 million dollars and just to put that
into perspective an NFL team salary cap
is 224.8 million the whole team combined
can make that and this one guy is making
almost that in one year he's making
almost 18 million dollars a month which
is 589 thousand dollars a day benzema's
contract is insane though just to
compare Messi makes 41 million a year
and mimbabe makes 63 million a year